Je suis grand voyant et tu n'entends que le son de ma voix.
J'ai un accent qui part n'importe comment mais c'est pas grave.
Je suis en train de devenir un petit peu espagnol.
Revenons à l'accent un peu russe
Comme je suis voyant, j'ai la réponse à la question que tu te poses toi
Il est un peu brésilien mon voyant
Ne rigole pas car j'ai même la réponse à la question que tu ne t'es pas encore posée
Et nous allons la poser ensemble
Pour ça j'ai besoin aide numérologie
Pas mot clé sinon Fabien Olicart sait à distance
Je te demande de penser à ton âge maintenant
Tu penses à ton âge maintenant et tu te concentres sur le dernier chiffre de ton âge
Si ton âge c'est 112 ans, tu penses qu'à 2
Si ton âge c'est 16 ans, tu penses à 6
Si ton âge c'est 50 ans, pas bien, tu prends le 5
Si ton âge c'est 30 ans, pas bien, tu prends le 3
Tu prends le dernier chiffre de ton âge SAUF si c'est un 0
En clair, prenez pas le 0 quoi
Je prends aussi dernier chiffre de mon âge, le 9 parce j'ai 29 ans
On ne rit pas sur l'âge du grand voyant
Et tu vas multiplier le dernier chiffre de ton âge par le dernier chiffre de mon âge
Si tu as 22 ans, tu fais 2*9
Si tu as 13 ans, tu fais 3*9
57 ans, 7*9
Nous sommes en train de croiser le destin
Maintenant numérologie
Tu vas réduire le résultat que tu as dans ta tête
Si ton résultat, c'est 14 tu additionnes 1 et 4 pour faire 5
Jusqu'à temps de n'avoir plus qu'un seul chiffre dans ta tête
Tu comprends la logique de la numérologie croisée
Et maintenant écoutes moi bien, c'est très très important
Tu vas enlever 5 à ton résultat
Mais si tu peux pas enlever 5, si ton résultat final c'est 4, alors tu ajoutes 3
Tu enlèves 5 et si c'est pas possible tu ajoutes 3
Et tu maintenant le résultat de notre destinée croisée numérologique
Alors je vais afficher la liste des questions possibles pour cette voyance en ligne
Voici la liste des questions
Regardes la question qui correspond à ton résultat et je vais essayer d'y trouver la réponse
Lis la question qui correspond à ton résultat dans ta tête
Et je crois avoir la réponse
Oui j'ai la réponse à ta question, pour t'abonner à la chaîne il suffit de cliquer ici
Juste là
Si c'est bien la  réponse à ta question alors fais le
Vous savez que le dimanche c'est toujours quelque chose qui vous permet de bluffer vos amis
Et bien c'est le cas vous allez pouvoir les bluffer en leur faisant ça
Alors vous faites votre liste de question à vous, avec votre point d'interrogation sur une feuille de papier par exemple
Vous mettez vos questions et vous faites faire à la personne exactement la même chose que ce que moi je vous ai fais faire
Attention pensez bien à prendre le 9 comme multiplicateur
C'est la clé de tout ce tour qu'on à fait ensemble là juste à l'instant
Faites le à vos amis cette semaine, bluffez les, amusez vous, abonnez vous
Profitez bien de ce dimanche et rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain mental vlog, tchao
**bétisier**